the waters still Sparkle here on the
Tana Kenya's longest river it's a
thousand kilometers long and provides
the basis of life for animals and humans
alike but some spots along the Tana have
dried up leaving just rocks and sand the
operator of a hydroelectric power plant
has diverted several kilometres of the
river to a nearby dam through an
underground tunnel
marianna pious walks two hours every day
to fetch drinking water for herself and
her family of 10 she is outraged used to
flow along here but then the first Dam
was built and it was reduced to a
trickle after the second dam was built
it disappeared altogether Simon has a
quitter it's 33 degrees Celsius in the
shade only the water provides relief
from the heat
the locals cool off wash and get their
drinking water here all in the one place
the water is almost lukewarm providing
perfect conditions for waterborne
pathogens to thrive problems at the
hospital they told me it was caused by
amoeba and other side effects from the
water but I don't have any alternative
because there's no other water around so
we have to use what's here Lydia Alaka
is here for the first time the scientist
works for the University of Nairobi zwei
ZUP project the goal of the project is
to defuse the conflict between the
different groups who use the water her
data is meant to help find sensible ways
of using the little water available what
is life
there are two issues of just
the quantity of water so either a lot or
too little and then the other thing is
the quality issues that we have ADA
water that is a very poor quality and
water that is of good quality so these
are the two extremes within Kenya just
depends on where you are and where there
is no water conflicts are escalating in
recent years further down the river
fights over grazing land and water have
even resulted in death some residents
believe climate change is the main
culprit others blame the dams nearly
half of Kenya's electricity is produced
here making the dams crucial for the
country's industrial development the
power company has little interest in
cooperating with the research project
but that's not deterring the scientists
the electricity company is very
important because one of the component
of wise up is actually looking at the
built infrastructure and looking at the
effect of the dams on the river and this
is one of the big components because it
really their decisions will affect the
natural flow of the river and everything
all data is to be analyzed by 2016 but
so far progress on the project has been
sluggish redundant structures
bureaucracy and hierarchies are just
some of the issues hindering
communication between project partners
and each partner has his own interests
so really why SAP is important in trying
to look at all the water demands within
the catchment and really the
distribution to have the environmental
needs the needs of the people and also
the development of the country
managing the China River is complex just
like its ecosystem to understand the
river or Larker travels to one of its
tributaries the interests of the locals
here are different from what she's seen
before the people don't want to use the
river for industrial purposes but to
preserve nature one of the best to give
a [ __ ] a big [ __ ] to cover the river
also gives no Kanaan or soil erosion
because of the loots you know they
protects their ocean yeah over the past
few years they've been planting forests
along the river it's a long-term project
supported by the government shade from
the trees should help prevent
evaporation of the river water 5 10
years from now this divide completed
rights completely there was no Prato but
you can see the water is not flowing we
are proud of that because as leaders we
can see what we have done and also
people are appreciating us so we are
very much proud the locals share their
knowledge and experience with the
scientists they're glad to talk about
the project because the forestation
benefits everyone along the river this
is the dream to have a clean clear like
what we have seen here and if you
compare this to what we are seeing
downstream you actually see that it
collects a ton of things as it goes down
so we hope that all the stakeholders who
are involved in this process can really
see the F the benefits of reclaiming a
river and this will produce clean water
that's something Marianna pious can only
dream about the dry season has just
started
she doesn't benefit from the
hydroelectric power plant
she doesn't have electricity
she doesn't care about that she just
wants clean water to get through the day
you